can i thank the whole house for the way
the tributes to sir david were handled
on monday
we saw the best of this house and i want
to see if we can use that collaborative
spirit to make progress on one of the
issues that was raised on monday
tackling violent extremism
it's three years since the government
promised an online safety bill
but it's not yet before the house
meanwhile the damage caused by harmful
content online is worse than ever
dangerous algorithms on facebook and
instagram
and hope not have shown me an example of
violent islamism
and far-right
propaganda on tick-tock
what i was shown has been reported to
the moderators
but it stayed online because apparently
it didn't contravene the guidelines
after i find that hard to believe
so will the prime minister build on the
desire shown by this house on monday to
get things done
and commit to bring forward the second
reading of the online safety bill by the
end of this calendar year
if he does
we'll support it
prime minister uh mr speaker i thank the
right honourable gentleman for the
spirit in which he has approached this
issue and i echo what he says about the
need for cooperation across the house
because the safety of of mps indeed of
all uh public servants everybody who
engages with the public is of vital
importance and uh the online safety bill
is of of huge importance to uh it's one
of the most important tools in our
armory and what we're doing is ensuring
that we crack down on uh companies that
promote illegal and uh and dangerous
content and we'll be uh toughening up uh
those provisions but mr speaker what we
are also going to do is ensure that uh
the online safety bill does complete uh
its uh its stages uh before this house
uh before uh before christmas and i'm
delighted uh or rather that we do bring
forward uh the uh bring it forward
before christmas in the way that he uh
the way that he suggests and i'm
delighted mr speaker that he is uh
offering his support and uh and we look
forward to that
kirsten
thank you mr speaker i thank the prime
minister i think from that um this isn't
a challenge it's to clarify that the
pre-legislative scrutiny will be
finished um before in early december and
that the second reading could i think be
before at the end of this calendar year
um but we do need to get on with this
telegram has been described as the app
of choice for extremists
and mr speaker if you can believe it if
the house can believe it
as we were paying tribute to sir david
on monday
telegram users could access
videos of murders
and violent threats against politicians
the lgbt community women and jews as we
were paying our respects
some of these posts are illegal
all of them are harmful
and
hope not hate and the board of deputies
have said that telegram has in their
words facilitated and nurtured a
subculture that cheerleads for
terrorists
tough sanctions are clearly needed
yet under the government's current
proposals directors of platforms failing
to crack down on extremism would still
not face criminal sanctions
why is that
prime minister mr speaker this is this
government that brought forward an
online uh harms bill mr speaker he's
heard uh it's he's heard what i've said
he's heard what i've said about uh about
the second reading before christmas and
you know in the collegiate spirit in
which uh he he he announced his uh he
began his questioning i can tell him
that we will uh continue to look at ways
in which we can toughen up those
provisions and to come down hard on
those who irresponsibly allow
dangerous and extremist content uh to
permeate the internet but mr speaker uh
i i'm delighted that uh he's taking this
this new uh tough line and i very much
hope uh that he can be that he will get
the rest of his party in the lobbies
with us to join him
mr speaker i did start in the collegiate
spirit and i'll continue in a collegiate
spirit because i listened hard to what
was being said on the opposite benches
on monday about the concerns about this
issue
and we do need
to recognize the measures in the bill
but we do need tough and effective
sanctions and that means criminal
sanctions and that does matter mr
speaker
it is frankly beyond belief that as the
mirror reported yesterday
40 hours of hateful content from anjem
choudary could be easily accessed online
the prime minister and the government
could stop this by making it clear
that directors of companies are
criminally liable for failing to tackle
this type of material on their site
we don't need to delay so in the
collaborative spirit we saw in this
house on monday will the prime minister
commit to taking this away
looking at it again and working with all
of us to strengthen his proposed
legislation
i've already said that we're willing to
uh look at anything to strengthen the
legislation i've said that we're willing
to uh bring it forward and we will bring
it forward to second reading before
christmas and yes of course mr speaker
we will have criminal sanctions uh with
tough sentences uh for those who are
responsible for allowing this foul
content to permeate the internet and mr
speaker but what we hope for also is
that no matter how tough the proposals
we produce that the honor of the
opposition will support it
[Music]
uh mr speaker we're making progress
we've got the second reading committed
to before christmas that is a good thing
and i think the prime minister is now
committed to criminal sanctions at the
moment they're a fallback position
um at the discretion of the minister
they should be in my view on the face of
the bill as the automatic default for
the failure now if you're making
progress on that then we're beginning to
address some of the issues that were
identified across the house on monday
can i turn to the
um report the commission for countering
extremism which was set up in the wake
of the horrific manchester bombings
eight months ago that commission made
recommendations to plug gaps in existing
legislation and strategy
gaps that extremists have been able to
exploit and are continuing to exploit
yet sir mark rowley formerly head of our
counterterrorism policing who led on
those recommendations said just this
week
i've had no feedback from the home
office on their plans in relation to our
report on the absence of a coherent
legal framework to tackle hateful
extremism
given the seriousness of the matter and
the clear need for action
why has the government not responded to
this important work and will the prime
minister now commit to act swiftly on
the commission's recommendations
prime minister mr speaker the government
to my right on the home secretary works
with all parties to tackle violent
extremism and the uk has one of the
strongest uh counter terrorism and
counter extremism systems in the world
as a consequence of which we have foiled
31 terrorist plots since 2017 and i pay
tribute to the work of of sir mark
rowley with whom i worked extremely
closely while i was in london and
all those who are involved in foiling
those terrorist pots and i can uh tell
you mr speaker that they will receive
the complete support of this house and
and of this this government nor will we
allow them to be released of those who
are convicted to be released early from
prison mr speaker because that was one
of the most important things this
government passed in which that party
opposed
pierstama
really our very
either we take this either we take this
seriously and i'm taking my lead from
those on the opposite benches on monday
and what they were saying about the need
to tackle this either we take it
seriously and go forward together or we
do a disservice to those that we pay
tribute to
there are clearly problems
there are clearly problems with the
government's counter-extremism strategy
internet users are increasingly likely
to come across extremist content online
the government's own independent
reviewer has said that there is no
evidence that the government's key
de-radicalization program is effective
that's the government's independent
reviewer saying that and we've seen a
spate of lone attack killings with the
perpetrator invariably radicalized
online
we all want to stop this across this
house but at the moment things are
getting worse not better so what urgent
plans does the prime minister have to
fix these glaring problems
prime minister well mr speaker i'm more
i'm all in favor of uh collegiate and
cooperative uh approach and and and then
in which case i think it would be a fine
thing if the uh opposition would
withdraw their opposition to our
measures to stop the early release of of
serious extremist and violent offenders
that's all that's all i'm trying to say
in a clinically intercollegiate approach
and i'm i'm sure that that is what the
people of this country will wish to see
but we will continue to do everything
that we can to strengthen our
counterterrorism
operation and to support all those who
are involved in keeping us safe and
obviously it is too early to draw any
particular conclusions from the
appalling killing of our of our
colleague uh but we will draw all
relevant conclusions from that
investigation
thank you mr speaker the inescapable
desire of this house on monday to
finally clamp down on the extremism the
hate and the abuse that festers online
is incredibly welcome
but closing down anonymous accounts
would not have prevented the murder of
joe cox
nor of pc keith palmer
and although we don't know the full
circumstances surrounding his death
nor would it have saved sir david
if we're to get serious about stopping
violent attacks
we need to stop online spaces being safe
spaces for terrorists
we need to ensure that unaccountable
arrogant social media companies take
responsibility for their platforms
we need to end the delays get on with
the legislation and clean out the
cesspit once and for all
mr speaker i've prosecuted terrorists
and i've prosecuted extremists i've
worked with sir mark and others
dozens of labour mps have worked hard on
tackling social media companies on these
issues i started collegiately and i'll
continue collegiately
we know what it takes we can help so
will the prime minister now capture the
spirit that we've seen this week and
agree to work with us on a cross-party
basis so we can tackle violent extremism
and it's enablers together
mr speaker i'm i'm delighted to uh to
join the uh right honourable gentleman
in uh committing to tackle tackling
online harms uh together to tackling
violent extremism together and that that
is what uh the government is doing and
that's why we brought forward the online
harms bill uh that's why we're investing
uh record sums in tackling
terrorism uh but mr speaker i must say
that what i think the whole country in
the whole house would certainly want to
see in addition in addition if i can say
this to the to the right honourable
gentleman
in a collegiate spirit in addition is a
commitment uh by the labour party in
future to support measures and not to
allow the early release of those
terrorists and those who are convicted
of those offenses from prison and i if
you could hear that from the labour
party i think it would be a fine thing